jeudi les chiffres encore aujourd'hui à
sin on pouvait pas passer à côté de cet
événement hier hier dans plusieurs
villes de france
il ya eu des manifestations de soutien à
la famille de sarah halimi dans toute la
france 25 mille personnes ont protesté
hier à paris c'est vrai qu'elle est
beaucoup beaucoup de monde selon la
préfecture plus de vingt mille
participants et je vous dis de ce qu'on
sait il paraît que il peut y avoir une
révision
oui mais voilà de la décision de justice
donc c'est incroyable donc ça a fait
bouger les choses je voudrais remercier
les organisateurs qui m'ont laissé de
nombreux messages pour me dire que c'est
aussi grâce au ramdam qu'on a fait dans
tpm paix que les choses ont bougé donc
merci à eux
surtout c'est pas du tout grâce à des
pmp c'est surtout grâce pour voir la
williams hocine oui le frère de sarah
halimi qui a été exceptionnel voilà sur
ce plateau et je pense qu'il a touché
tout le monde
donc bravo
[Applaudissements]
j'ai mangé j'y suis allé et un moment
vous êtes apparu sur grand écran comme
ça et je peux vous dire que la foule
ça a été un triomphe il ya eu d'autres
personnes avant vous et après vous je
peux dire que vous laissez pas se faire
plaisir énorme ça a été alors les gens
quand on a vu cyril hanouna en gros plan
comme ça j'ai reconnu c'était filmé dans
votre gourbis là haut et c'est vrai vous
savez courbit oui dans votre vestiaire
là où et vous étiez impeccable et les
gens vraiment ça a été un triomphe je
peux vous dire ça m'a fait plaisir
[Applaudissements]